foreign
buckle your seat belt because in this
video we're going to be learning from
two different creators who are earning
money on YouTube in seven different ways
in fact we're going to be talking about
seven different ways to earn a thousand
dollars on YouTube and also we have a
special clip from one of today's top
YouTube creators on why now is the best
time to be a content creator going into
2023 in fact we're going to kick it off
and start with that if you haven't heard
of valutainment before valuetainment is
getting about 12 million views a month
almost 4 million subscribers and
recently I sat down with Patrick Bet
David and the founder of value
attainment to learn about his
perspective on why now is the best time
to be a content creator and you know
there's a lot happening in the world
there's a looming recession there's
different fears in the economy the stock
market is down but one of the things
that Patrick David pbd for short said
was actually one of the ways to hedge
against the recession how to be
Recession Proof is actually to join the
Creator economy listen to uh his
perspective really quick and then we're
going to get into the main content what
is your advice for entrepreneurs content
creators right now those that want to
prepare and position their self what are
a few moves they can make to be very
serious about right now I mean for
Content creators covid and the shutdown
was great for Content creators meet
Kevin came out of nowhere and all of a
sudden he had a million and a half gram
Stefan went from I don't know he was at
four 500 000 Subs I think he's at four
million Subs now you got a bunch of
people that blew up during covet because
when people are afraid they listen so
when people are afraid they need to be
entertained so when a person stressed
out sometimes they just want to watch a
comedy film they have no desire to watch
a overly you know scary you know let me
tell you what's going on with the market
like dude I just want to break just make
me laugh you know so you notice when
covet hit what went to the roof alcohol
went to the roof beer companies went to
the roof liquor went to the roof
entertainment went to the roof tiger
king became a celebrity where he was
running for office not to be a president
who would have thought we're going to
watch Tiger King 64 million people are
going to log on to Netflix in the first
three weeks and watch Tiger King who's
Tiger King so far content creators if
they position themselves right in areas
that people want I think it's going to
be a very good season for Content
creators who position themselves the
right way
yeah so what is the big idea here we're
about to learn seven different ways to
make a thousand dollars on YouTube but I
want to encourage you now is the time to
get positioned to prepare now to be
positioned the right way to position
your channel right your video strategy
right your money plan right because
during recessions during the lockdown
and all the way back when I started my
YouTube channel during the 2008 9-10
recession that was a time that
eventually built to where think media is
today it's actually an opportunity for
you if you position yourself right to
serve people Mission driven solving
problems and we're actually going to
learn from our creators today that I
interview in this exclusive clip that we
are diving into and so let me just pull
up this clip that was prepared for a
very smooth live stream transition and
is no longer perfectly prepared smoothly
but I still have it and here it comes
all right out how to make your first or
next one thousand dollars from YouTube
we're gonna be learning from some
incredible creators
um just kind of learning about their
journey and their story and so we're
talking about five ways plus two bonus
strategies that you've never heard
before and so buckle your seatbelt and I
actually want to welcome our guest today
and first I want to welcome plants and
Lucia Lucia is a plant educator and
content creator on YouTube how's it
going good to see you hi yeah I'm so
happy to be here thank you so much for
inviting me so before we welcome Jay Ben
tell us a little bit when did you start
YouTube what is the journey been like
and uh a little bit of your story
yeah
um well I started YouTube three years
ago I have a channel called plants and
Lucia and it's primarily based on
helping people that want to bring nature
to their homes but they're planned
beginners so they don't know so much
about plant care and they just want to
learn more about nature and having just
plants around them on a daily basis
and it's actually really it's really
interesting because I was there three
years ago I wanted to bring nature to my
home I was not super happy at my job and
I would just go hiking or go to the
forest and I felt just centered and calm
with myself and with nature so I wanted
to bring that to the to my house but I
just didn't know how so I just started
learning by myself and then I thought I
would love to share this with other
people so I thought maybe YouTube could
be a good way because I was learning a
lot in YouTube too but I just didn't
know how to get into YouTube so that's
when I found you Sean actually in VRA so
before I even started my channel I
decided to sign up for VRA and just
learn about YouTube to see if it was a
good fit for me and that's when I
learned that YouTube is a system that
you can actually use and learn from to
get to other people like you and kind of
spread your message and get to the right
people and yeah and then fast forward
three years now and the community is
more than four thousand sorry forty
thousand people now and we're all
learning together our plans and it's
really beautiful so now I'm just very
happy to be here to share with you my
experience with YouTube and how I've
been able to
get some income also from this community
but not only that also many other really
beautiful things with the community so
yeah yeah I'm very happy to be here and
share that with you
oh I can't wait to get into it I've got
so many questions for you and I'm
excited to learn all of the things and
thanks so much for being here but we
also have jabin from postal barbecue
what's up Javen thanks for being on yeah
thanks a lot Sean
you know it's crazy because we actually
go back uh Jaden he'll tell a little bit
of his story but as a filmmaker in
addition to this barbecue Channel That's
Now 51 000 subscribers uh but we
actually go back like over a decade and
I used to do a non-profit called think
International with my friend Jeff and
we're at a conference together and Javen
helped film and he was doing photography
then and so uh it's been crazy to also
be in this journey of YouTube and just
see him his family's kids and all this
stuff but Jason tell us about your
YouTube journey and uh just a little bit
about uh what you do on YouTube
yeah so I started this whole YouTube
journey in the barbecue Niche
um back in uh end of 2014 beginning
2015. uh and it really all kind of came
organically because around that time I
had uh one of my sons who I was born
with food allergies and so we couldn't
go out as a family anywhere to eat and
uh and so I just decided at that moment
I always loved to cook I always loved to
grill and so I decided that moment if we
can't go out for food to a restaurant or
whatever then I'm gonna cook the best
barbecue that I know how possible for my
kids so they can enjoy life in the
flavors of life and uh fast forward
throughout time
um moving to 2020 when the pandemic hit
it shut down everything else that I was
doing uh and allowed me to go full time
uh with Pulsa barbecue and just creating
weekly recipes for the YouTube world and
it's been a lot of fun it's been a great
adventure so far and uh yeah Sean I
still remember talking to you uh back at
that one conference and
um just thinking and having that
conversation about one day becoming a
household name in the barbecue world and
uh and so step by step we're slowly
moving towards that and so it's pretty
cool to see
well and there's a couple I mean you can
see a little little product placement
there there's there's the postal
barbecue original rub and I can't wait
to talk about so many little nuances and
tips you have for us earning money but
it's also kind of crazy is you've been a
part of like the generations of VRA you
know we continue to improve video
ranking Academy and and still uh where
uh anyone who gets in we're giving all
future uh lifetime uh updates to new
information it back then it was called
VRA 1.0 then there was 2.0 then we did
read it we got rid of the 0.0s now it's
foundations and we're adding Masters uh
to it that's coming March 1st and you
know you get that when you get into the
growth video live accelerator so just in
this journey and I can't wait to get
into all the details and it's been cool
to see
um that you know your race your pace too
we're all at different times seasons of
Life you've been doing different type of
work and it's so cool to see that during
the pandemic you had an asset because
you had been investing in YouTube and uh
that it's been able to be something
that's helped you go full time but let's
get into it and we're going to be
talking about ways to make money it's
kind of our theme today and we've got
the five main ways
um that we're going to be talking about
and the first one kind of just has to be
talked about and that is YouTube ads
right YouTube AdSense and so let's start
with you uh Lucia
um do you do you remember when your
channel got monetized and what has been
your experience with earning money
directly from views on your videos
yeah
um actually yeah I remember when I got
monetized uh it was of course when
I mean you get to the 1000 subscribers
and the 44 000 hours and then you can
apply for the monetization I didn't
apply right away because I was trying to
build a community and kind of like build
a relationship with our with the
community in plants in Lucia but I
remember once I I actually got monetized
and I started monetizing my videos
um yeah of course I started seeing a
difference I I it was it was some income
for the channel and it was really great
to have that extra income to keep making
the content
um the one thing that I can say is that
it was it is one of the types of income
that I have in YouTube that I see that
um is great in terms of finances and
financing the channel but it's also
limiting in the sense that you are not
connecting with the audience with this
uh with this type of income right it's
just uh it's just an app that is right
before the video or in the video and
yeah I mean it's good in terms of
financing the work but uh but I think
other types of income can actually help
you uh get more than just the income and
actually connect with the audience
yeah 100 like it's kind of sometimes we
even call it like a tip jar like once
you get uh kind of approved it's nice it
brings in some extra income but there's
so many better ways and we're gonna be
talking about those today
um but jabin do you remember when you
got monetized and what's kind of some of
your tips and thoughts about YouTube ad
Revenue
yeah I think uh when it comes to YouTube
ad Revenue it's probably the most common
question people ask you because you're
on YouTube right and um I personally got
monetized right off the bat because it
was again back in 2014 there wasn't
really any sort of criteria on who or
who couldn't really be monetized and uh
so when the newer system hit with
thousand subscribers and all that stuff
that was already past that and so uh but
I remember getting that first hundred
dollar uh check from Google and I was so
pumped it was such a great feeling it
probably took about a year at that point
because you know the channel was quite
slow to start with
um but for me YouTube ads has really
just been
um the bread and butter
um it's the piece that you know I plan
into my budgeting
um because you know it's it's gonna be
there it's not going to be a lot but at
least it's it's the one piece that you
can sort of rely on uh every month you
in and out of the brand deals or
whatever other source of income that
fluctuate up and down a lot it's your
constant
um like I said it's not it's not massive
but it's enough to sort of make some
planning especially if you're in a niche
that you know requires funds to purchase
you know a hundred dollars worth of meat
or whatever product it is
um it keeps you going sort of thing yeah
I love that and if you are new to
YouTube ad Revenue
um officially you need to get a thousand
subscribers and then you need to get 4
000 hours of watch time within the last
12 months and that's always kind of
rolling so it has to be within a
12-month window then that just makes you
eligible to apply once you apply it
sometimes takes around a month to get
approved and so the good news is there
are other ways to earn money even before
you get approved for the YouTube
um AdSense uh program and if you want to
do a little bit of math uh what the way
that they measure how much they pay you
is based on what's called CPM and that's
just how much you get paid per it's cost
per Mill and Mill is a thousand it's how
much you get paid per thousand views not
every view you get will be monetized an
ad might not play someone might have an
ad blocker but however many ads actually
play on your videos like that's rough
numbers if you got a hundred thousand
views Maybe be only sixty thousand or
seventy thousand would actually be
monetized views and so a lot of times
people CPM will be two dollars uh in
that's a lower CPM two to five on kind
of entertainment content and then as you
go up and maybe a Content where the
audience has more buying power it might
be ten dollar cpms 20 30 40 50 in the
personal finance Niche Niche or crypto
and nfts it could be a hundred dollar
amazon e-commerce CPM I threw a lot at
you there
um but if you have questions we'll have
some time a little bit to ask our guests
some questions today but it brings us to
tip number two which we learned during
RSP review specific products and that's
affiliate marketing and so Lucia I'm
curious have you Incorporated affiliate
marketing into any of your content and
what have you learned
yeah actually affiliate marketing was
the first type of income or the first
type of way that I actually Incorporated
in my content because when I started
learning what my audience was looking
for because okay my channel is an
education an educational Channel and
it's for plant beginners so then I
thought maybe affiliate marketing is a
very good way it's a it's a good
strategy to incorporate in for example
two types of videos I started
incorporating it in tutorials and also
in another type of video that I also
learned here uh we think with the think
media team and that one is
um best blank four to blank so for
example for the tutorial videos those
don't work really good because people
are looking for methods to care for
their plans
so one example would be for example
potting mix so how to make a potting mix
for your succulents I really like making
my own potting mix because you touch the
soil and you know what you're putting in
the potting mix for the plant
so and I know that many people in my
community also want to make their own
potting mix and depending on the plant
is different ingredients so then I
thought okay maybe this is a very good
tutorial for people to learn about this
and the way that I do it is I just tell
them the method step by step and then I
also tell them okay you know what now
I'm going to teach you all of the
ingredients that I use at specific
ingredients and why I use them and this
is very helpful because people are
actually looking for this specific
question and I'm just giving them the
recipe and making it making it easier
for them to find the ingredients in the
description so then it's a win-win right
like people actually go and check the
what I used and yeah it's really cool
actually so that's the first type of
video that I use with affiliate
marketing it's been really good for the
channel and for the community and the
second type is another one that is
actually like a list so best blank to
blank so for example today Heather was
talking about in the session today about
jumping into Trends and right now in the
plant Community spring is coming finally
I mean still a month to go but it's
almost here and we actually really love
propagating our plants but of course
this is very intimidating because it
depends on the plant and you don't know
which type of propagation you should do
so for example for me I really like
reading books about this and I was
thinking maybe a good video would be my
top five books to learn about plant
propagation so then I solve a problem
with for the viewer because they want to
learn about the methods they want to
learn where or what tools to use and
then it's also good because I put all of
the tools in the description and they
can actually find it which is really
yeah it's really good so these are the
two videos that I usually incorporate
affiliate marketing and it's been really
great for the channel and I also see
that the community really appreciate it
and it's really cool because then they
actually comment on the video and
they're like yeah I actually I actually
tried that product that you recommended
and it works for me so it's also a way
to connect with the community actually
just suggesting the the products and the
tools that are going to be helpful for
them so yeah I really like it that's so
cool and we our definition of affiliate
marketing is sharing the products you
love and use it's not like a weird pushy
thing you're here helping people and
they're like thanks so they don't know
you're the the plant Master you're the
expert you're the one I look to you you
know all I know for me is I kill my
plants like I mean I don't intentionally
kill them I just don't know what to do
and so I have to buy new ones new
succulents for my office at the store
but uh practically
um here in the challenge if you look in
the description you can see that um
she's got a link for a free trial of
Amazon audible that's really smart
um and that can um I believe you
actually get a bounty is what Amazon
gives you if somebody signs up for
um this and it's called a bounty because
they even want the truck they'll pay you
just for the trial of someone signing up
and then these are affiliate links to
books on Amazon and remember that if
anybody clicks your link
whether they buy the that product or not
for 24 hours anything they purchase ends
up getting credited to you and so um how
has been what would you say
percentageally uh Affiliates is when it
comes to your overall pie of what you
earn on YouTube
I think right now I mean it's not the
biggest but it's maybe 30 percent or
something like this so it's actually
pretty good yeah I I'm still trying to
find the best strategy but right now
it's actually working really well for me
for sure man I love it that's so cool
well Jayden uh you know I remember early
on one of my favorite videos with you
was barbecue accessories around Father's
Day which really ties in and I think
friends you can see these strategies
Trend surfing Father's Day meets RSP
meets you know uh review specific
products and and uh that was a video he
made years ago but but what has
affiliate marketing
um what are some of the strategies
you've done or stories uh when it comes
to your content
yeah so affiliate marketing um I've done
as early on as as I could uh basically
and that was that was
um I was introduced to that because of
VRA
um and you because it was you start to
talk about you know how much more you
could actually make uh over top of your
YouTube ads and it kind of just
intrigued me and so I started doing it
fairly early on and
um it's been it's been great so far I
try to incorporate it uh as much as I
can I love what you just said about
um
sharing the products that you love and
use all the time and having those is
sort of your Baseline of affiliate
marketing links and things like that
because people I find that people look
to to us as creators as influencers
people like that to sort of glean what
they might want especially in their
Niche and so if I'm using a thermometer
I'm always going to be talking about
that thermometer and even saying like
there's a link in the description for
you and it just takes them to that
purchasing place right and then you get
that commission and it's great
um you know how often do you have people
that just say hey if you help me sell
this I'll give you some money and it can
really be beneficial and so for me I've
like you said the um that Gear review
their father's day gift guide I think it
was
um was sort of the one of the first
things I I did to really begin to tap
into that and it's still you know I
think it was like four years ago and
it's still ranked in the top
um the top you know six results and uh
yeah there's right there I don't even
have a hat on in that one
um since then I've actually redone that
video with new products this is just
last uh like a year ago and
um basically exactly the same style
video uh just with updated products and
it's even ahead of
um that last one I think it's actually
the number one search result right now
for barbecue gift ideas and all of those
things have links in the description box
from Amazon to Brand specifics and the
great thing that I love about affiliate
marketing is yo you may not make a lot
from one company but if you think about
it like buckets then those buckets when
you collect all of them and dump them
into like a larger bucket all of a
sudden it goes up and up and up to the
point where it actually you can you know
cache that in for a good chunk of money
every single month and I've had months
where it's
um it Rivals and is even or above the
YouTube ads uh because you know in my
Niche summertime is from Spring to Fall
is a huge market and so brands people
are buying more in those those seasons
and they're using your links I'll put
them on my website even with discount
codes and just kind of helping to
reinforce that mindset of you shop
through this and you can even get 10 off
yourself or whatever have you that the
brand has sort of
partnered with you with man so many
valuable tips and and what we're doing
here too what's really cool is we're
stacking because notice you know once
eventually you have ads going then you
also can have affiliate marketing going
but this is true multiple streams of of
income because next up we're going to be
talking about crowdfunding and uh plants
and Lucia this is actually something
that you have right here connected to
your channel up in the upper right hand
corner here it says subscribe and then
we have your patreon man I know there's
so many people here in the 1K challenge
that are curious what have you learned
about crowdfunding do you like patreon
what are some of the things you've
learned on the journey that you'd maybe
recommend if we wanted to uh go this
route of crowdfunding when it comes to
having a monetization stream for our
Channel
yes
um actually yeah I opened my patreon
last year
um at the end of last year the second
half
and it has become
uh one of my favorites actually to for
streams of income and the reason for
this is you know when I think about
um a financial strategy to finance the
work that I do and to grow this mission
that I have
um I always try to remind myself that
the end goal is not the money the money
of course is the means to get to what I
want to do with this community and the
mission that I comes from my heart and
the passion that I have
so crowdfunding is a very good way to
kind of like keep this in mind uh
because for example okay in Cloud
funding you can have either a patreon
page or you can work with
um buy me a coffee is another one or you
can do a Kickstarter so there are
different ways to do it in patreon for
example the one that I have you can have
either monthly memberships or you can do
um some other way that your patrons can
support your work by project in my case
it's actually by month
and the reason why I really love it is
because it gives you the opportunity to
actually share the passion and Mission
behind the content that you're creating
on YouTube or in other platforms with
the people that are following you and
you give them the space to
co-participate in that mission with you
that is not only financially which is
also a very great way to like
co-participate with admission for
example in patreon you have a space to
share with them your passion and also
learn from them in what they care about
as well related to your Niche for
example in my patreon we have a book
club for example that we talk about
nature writing and basically how to
connect with nature and what it means to
have a plan and what it means to care
for it and what it means to have a
relationship with it and it's really
beautiful to hear from them and actually
bring their perspective bring their
passions bring their ideas to the work
that I do not only with the financial
support that they that they give because
they believe in the mission they believe
in the work but also hearing them and
hearing their ideas and creating that
community in that space so I think yeah
crowdfunding has been really great at
least in my experience I love it because
I get to connect way more with my
community and yeah it's really great
man that's so awesome and that brings us
to number four which is create something
to sell and so which one do you like
best so far a 1K challenge which one do
you think suits your Niche maybe your
Channel best
um and when it comes to create something
to sell man there's so much opportunity
here I mean we're gonna learn from some
experts
um and their experience of so many
different things you could sell so jaben
I know that it's also I remember years
ago when you were just kind of getting
the rub started I actually haven't seen
it until it now you got the logo and
that's like some serious like it's like
mainstream I'm about to see it in the
local grocery store and so you have like
barbecue rubs of course you can create
things like online courses so what have
you learned under this idea of like
create something to sell
yeah so I right from the B like I once
talked with a guy
um that's within my Niche he had 30 000
subscribers he launched a barbecue rev
line and within like a year he took off
and it really just showed the power of
um how a personal brand can can leverage
uh itself to compete with the big boys
and uh yeah there's there's the revs and
so
after hearing that story I I kind of
took it upon myself to look into
barbecue rubs for myself and over the
years I went from you know just small
batch around Christmas to friends and
family to finally
um about a year a year and a bit ago
putting them into bottles uh creating
rebranding the whole channel the whole
brand and getting them into bottles that
would then be sold through a brand new
website
um and it's been great like
um because every video that that is
created is now using my own line of rubs
and so the more people that begin to
follow the more they're seeing those
rubs use all the time which means that
they're more likely to to go over to the
website for not just the recipes but
then to the shop and purchase items from
me uh and in my experience having a
physical product back because people
look to you with this sort of celebrity
mentality
um they're more likely to purchase from
you rather than you know just a big box
store brand that they see all the time
because it's special they've committed
hours and hours of their time watching
your content and so if they can have a
little bit of whatever product you have
um it's for them it's it's just
something that's just more special than
just that generic product and so for me
barbecue rubs have been a big thing I've
I've went to the merch route as well
which isn't as
um fast of of a of a growth thing in
terms of sales but you know with all of
these strategies you have you always
have to start somewhere even if you only
are going to sell you know 100 100
bottles of rubs a year you know that's
where you start and if you don't start
there you're never going to get to your
end result man that's so encouraging
that you say that because it's also it's
you know you gotta you can't steer a
parked car no and once you start getting
some momentum though now it's about
scaling I mean you got to sell one thing
before you know one bottle One customer
up during Christmas a lot of the biggest
brands started in a garage and it's
maybe not our ambition to become a big
brand but to just start small and then
scale and get better as we go and I
think there's a real power tip here
because not only so many tips power
personal branding people really do they
would rather connect with the person and
they'd rather connect with somebody that
was also maybe you've educated them
you've helped them they want to use the
rub you're using they're seeing the
whole experience
um and so that's powerful but I love
that eventually you built a website and
I think that's a power tip because
notice here on the postal barbecue
website a couple things David's in
Canada so the prices are in Canadian but
up top it says shopping from the USA our
Shop prices are Canadian dollars which
means you can save even more so he's got
uh you're shipping to us and Canada then
yes where will you ship yeah so I
currently ship uh direct all across
Canada all across uh the U.S even to
Hawaii and Australia
um I have a retailer now in Australia
um and I just lined up three more
retailers in um in the western western
Canada this week and uh and so you
talked about scaling you know start
somewhere then you have to scale you
know I'm at the point where I need to
now start thinking about you know large
capacity
um rub purchasing because you know this
year 2022
um it's not just about the YouTube
videos and the recipes is about growing
the personal brand which again will
reinforce the YouTube channel and it's
just a whole holistic cycle and so
reaching out to you know the thousands
of different barbecue stores just in
Canada Alone
um there's huge potential for sales to
just to increase and to to get you know
five new retailers every single month
without even really trying and so you
start somewhere and you keep going one
step in front of the other and
eventually you start crushing it and
people all along started from the bottom
now you're here but I want to go deeper
it's uh we got the rubs you mentioned
the merch and so Teespring and Teespring
can Teespring can integrate right below
it's a merch Shelf on YouTube as well
and then you even have you know
affiliate items and these are all right
here organized for people on the page so
again I love this just because we're
stacking right it's like now we're
adding eventually because you might go
well I don't know if I want to create
something to sew I don't have the time
to make a barbecue rubber I don't know
what I even would make but you don't
have to start there you can just add
things on as you go and I love that
jaben's encouraging us again it's about
starting messy it's about starting
before you're ready but as you go more
opportunity and doors will open up more
ideas will come your way as you continue
to learn and level up you'll say oh wow
not only am I glad that I posted some
videos because now I have this idea and
you can connect two things and all of a
sudden another level of money starts
flowing in but I want to ask Lucia you
know it's a little bit different for you
you've also created something to sell
and you're an education channel so in
your case you offer an online course on
plant care tell us a little bit about
that and where you host it and what
you've learned yes
um so basically I decided to to host a
course because I was getting many
questions in specific videos and
specific topics that went more into
detail so actually the topics were light
for plants and I started working with a
soft with a company called retrieve
so basically they do the back end and of
the course and then I create the content
and they helped me
um separate in chapters and also they
offer uh to translate the video so if
you want to like for example Spanish
German or whatever is your audience so I
thought that this was a good route for
me because I wanted to test it also
because I saw the need in my community
as they really were asking many
questions that I could not answer in one
YouTube video so I thought that this
could be a good way to answer their
questions and one other thing that I
really like about
creating a different product is that you
give options to your community so for
example some people like the YouTube
videos that's great some of the people
want to get involved with the content
and learn more for example in the
patreon page then that's also great for
some other people will be like you know
what I'm not ready to commit for a
monthly subscription on patreon but I
still want to learn more and be in
communication with Lucia so then they
can get to that hours and the cool thing
about it is that they can also chat with
me so then they have that service too
but it's only a one payment thing so
then you give your audience options and
you see what they need and then you see
okay maybe for some people the patreon
is going to be good then for other
people maybe this course is going to be
better so right now I tried actually
with the light course
um and then I saw that it was very
popular so now that spring is coming I'm
thinking about creating another course
and this one's going to be on Spring
care so it's gonna it's gonna talk about
maybe reporting and propagation and
other topics that come with spring
um and yeah maybe then later create a
bundle so we will see but it's actually
step by step I like what you were
talking about like step by step just
trying and seeing what is working and
learning in the process so yeah wow man
I I don't know if you're getting light
bulb moments 1K challenge but there's so
much uh so many nuggets in here and
remember we actually have two bonus tips
uh aft that are kind of outside of the
box after tip number five but tip number
five is sponsorships and brand deals now
at this level we're talking about where
a brand could be a barbecue brand right
it could be a plant brand or anything in
your Niche
um they want to pay you to make a video
um and so uh jabin what has been your
experience with paid sponsorships and
brand deals
yeah paid I like paid sponsorship deals
because they're they're often very
um straight to the point
um
you know like I I just the last one I
did was last week and force it was part
of a Super Bowl campaign and it only
took me like an afternoon to do and it
paid quite well and you know like when
you the more that you're in YouTube the
more that you become an authority in
your Niche the more likely Brands will
reach out to you or you'll make
connections that with people that are
connected with Brands and those people
will connect you to those Brands uh for
brand sponsorships brand deals and it
can be a lot of fun uh personally for me
I I've I've been working with a company
um for the past year and a bit now as
one of their creators for their Channel
they've contracted me out
um to so I have my own and then they've
you know like once a month I do
something for them on their Channel and
it's just a great source of extra income
and I'm I get to promote myself
um while being on their Channel and then
there's some cross promotion that goes
on it's pretty awesome so I don't know
did you did you catch that 1K challenge
not only has Javen done some paid
sponsorship deals on his channel but as
you build up your personal brand uh you
can get contracted to make videos for
another channel so now you're being paid
to make content now there's cross
promotion there there's awareness with
you in more places that's so powerful uh
well Lucia how about you what have you
learned
um when it comes to any kind of brands
or sponsors wanting to work with you on
your Channel
yeah I gotta say first that that was
very powerful because yeah making
content for another channel that didn't
occurred to me so that's really great
um yeah actually one thing that I can
say is that when I started thinking
about sponsorships when I was just
starting with the YouTube channel and
seeing like what what were my ways and
my past I thought okay sponsorships and
companies only want to work with big
channels like a hundred thousand
subscribers or a million subscribers
that's what I used to think but the more
I've learned and the more I I did this
work I started discovering that actually
companies really want to work with
smaller channels like mine or even
smaller
so I remember when I was at 1000 when
the community was 1 000 people 1 000
subscribers I started getting contacted
by companies because they wanted to work
with me and then I learned actually also
from Sean and from other research that I
did that companies really want to work
with smaller
channels and what is called micro
influencers because they see that we
have a connection a very intimate
connection with the community so if you
build trust with your community and
you're the community and like the
relationship is grounded in a genuine
authentic relationship with them then
first your audience sees it and they
trust your worth because you're genuine
and authentic and then also the company
see it so that's very valuable for them
too
so when I learned that I I was like okay
yeah maybe I can work with some
companies that also align with a mission
with the channel That the channel they
also aligned with the mission that I
have in the channel and also our
products that are gonna work with my
community so now that when I work with
companies I always think about this
think about the mission that I have do
the does their mission align with the
mission that I have in the channel and
do their products are going to be good
for the for the audience that I have and
if yes
then of course I'm gonna work with them
and that's really good because then the
community is also going to evaluate and
in the long term it's actually better
for the channel or for the companies and
for everyone I think
so yeah that was a really good framework
you just shared too when choosing who to
work with do I align with them do I like
their mission will they serve my
audience is this going to be a
win-win-win-win-win I think that's
that's the ultimate drain because it's
not like we want to sell out or or just
promote something but we want it to be a
win-win I mean this brand has on as a
mission if it's right for the audience
if we trust in it we believe in it we
also are being supported in our career
as a Creator or our YouTube channel and
so that was a really powerful framework
where we're going to do a couple uh
rapid fire bonus tips and then we'll
have time for just a few questions
because I'm sure you might have a
question or two
um but this is a really interesting one
uh that Jay been brought up as number
six local grants or just grants in
general so jabin break that down a
little bit uh this is definitely
probably one that nobody here has
thought about before and so uh tell us a
little bit about this yeah so this is
one of those things that I kind of just
fell into
um uh it was last summer a friend of
mine gave me a call and said hey I just
got a I just got
um I just got off a call from a local
television company and they have some
grant money left that was provided to
them in part by the government of Canada
and uh they're asked they asked if I had
knew of anyone that could meet some of
the needs for the grant money and so
they reached out to me and
um turns out a licensed old content that
was already
filmed in that prior year and just
repackaged it and sent it off to them
under license which means they don't
actually own it they own it for a
certain period of time and then it cuts
off and and then the that company
reached out again this year when the
when the applications came out and said
hey you need to apply for this again and
so I was like okay it worked last year
and uh so I reapplied and found out like
three weeks ago that I qualified and I
was chosen as one of the 90 grants and
part of it is you know it's I think it's
like six to eight episodes 20 to 25
minutes long each and the grant is 10
grand you know and so like
the only stipulation is that I can't
post those episodes on my channel until
after it's been submitted to them
approved by them and then I can post it
on my channel which for me is great
because I always have a hard time
filming in the winter time uh when it
starts raining and snowing and things
like that and so for me it's just this
year I'll have content uh guaranteed in
the winter time as I have a backlog of
new content and so it's it's great wow
there's always things like that out
there you know government uh big
companies
um you name it there it's out there you
just got to find it man that's that's
that also speaks to kind of like having
just that entrepreneurial spirit because
there's so many different ways and you
know it's funny you bring that up
because in some niches you obviously
have developed your film skills and it
and it speaks to the power of building a
skill set
um you know sometimes people like to
travel I mean let us know 1K challenge
if you'd want to make videos while
traveling the world you know eventually
you get a nice camera you maybe get a
drone and there's even another way
here's a bonus bonus tip that I don't
even have typed out and listed but you
can you can upload your footage to
places like istock video and places like
video Hive and actually get paid for
your b-roll clips for your uh clips that
other people can download and use and so
if you go somewhere and you film content
for your own YouTube channel or just for
your own hobby or your own passion you
can actually get licensing that's one of
the things that Jamie just mentioned
where someone's licensing your footage
the thing that you've created and it
could be a way of creating another
income stream and so there's just so
much opportunity out there in this world
but another one is working with brands
in trade so what do you do if especially
maybe you're early on and Brands don't
want to pay you yet you know maybe we'll
have time for Heather to to tell a story
she really breaks this down in other
places where when she was starting her
homeschool channel was in just the early
few first few hundred subscribers she
was able to get sixteen hundred dollars
of curriculum for free
but actually they also set up a
commission if she sold any of the
curriculum using her promo code then she
would make some commission and they paid
her to make a video when her channel was
just getting started the key was that it
was in a specific Niche but when you
really plant your flag
and and really position yourself well
strong personal brand Niche you know
find your niche
you can really get free products uh and
it might not always be an exchange of
money so Lucia have you ever had a brand
maybe send you something just not even
asking you to review it but if you want
to or not and what's been your
experience with just working in brands
for free products or in trade for for
free product to do a video for them or
that kind of thing
yeah it's been pretty amazing actually
it started uh well okay I do plant care
so uh one many many companies contact me
just to try other products and they
don't tell me to make any videos or
anything like that just do you like to
try our product so they send me girl
like sometimes it's like 300 sorry 300
Euros grow lights or
um soil or things that actually cost
money so this is also saving money which
is great for the business and also it's
extra money that you can use somewhere
else right and at the same time when you
try this product it's also an
opportunity to see if this brand can be
a good brand to work with in the future
so if you like the product and you get
to know a little bit more about them
this is also very good
um to just consider them as a partner
for the future and also for Content that
you would like to do if you like the
products that they send so yeah it's
been really great and I actually learned
from the products as well and from
different brands didn't know about
before so it's really it's really good
man it's so amazing and uh hey if you
have a question about making money on
YouTube or any of these six seven
strategies we've been sharing post four
question marks before and after your
question uh but Javen break it down
what's some free stuff you've got man
like what's some stuff that you've been
sent just listed out that maybe brands
have sent you because you built the
barbecue channel so uh what kind of
stuff have you got
um basically everything for the past
three years uh within the barbecue Niche
that I have has been sent to me uh
either they've reached out or I've
reached out to them and you know if I'm
gonna reach out to them I'm not
requiring anything it's more money saved
is money earned
um and so like for example this is uh
five ways to make your first thousand
dollars
um last summer I sort of evaluated the
channel and said I need to add pellet
rails to the lineup because pellet
grills are all the rage right now
they're simple to use and all this stuff
and so I did my research and said these
are the top two uh grills that I would
use in my in my videos and I reached out
to both companies and the one that I
liked the best uh got back to me and
said yeah we'll send you we'll send you
this Grill it was thinking it was like
sixteen hundred dollars uh converted to
Canadian and so right off the bat I
didn't have to fund that sixteen hundred
dollars for that Grill it's a great
Grill and it it's money saved is money
earned and if I had to go out and fund
that sixteen hundred dollars
um I I wouldn't have done it and so
working with Brands um is is great
especially if you're a smaller Channel
this is a this is a great way to sort of
get build up Your Arsenal of of either
things that you use or things that you
need to make your YouTube videos run a
little bit more smooth and the great
thing with all of that is you can always
opt into those those Brands affiliate
programs too and so if for me with this
product you know it's a sixteen hundred
dollar Grill
um they send it to me to use just
generally in the in the videos but then
I did a review video after I used it a
bunch of times gave all the specs sign
up for their affiliate program and just
the other day got a check from them you
know and it's it's just been sitting
there on autopilot and so you can kind
of you may not be making money off of
those deals but you're getting product
in replacement of money but then you're
making money off of it which is pretty
cool so strong Now isn't there a story
at one point when for at least a while
you were as a barbecue Channel getting
free meat
yeah no there was a there was a local
brand uh The Local Company that uh said
hey if you use our stuff and just sort
of mention us we'll provide all the meat
and uh so that was pretty cool uh it
didn't last for for as long as I hoped
uh because you know as as your brand
grows as the channel grows you you need
to sort of expand your horizons a little
bit but you know that was a local
business and there's a lot of power in
connecting with local businesses and
local Brands uh to start your first
sponsorships or to get products and I
have friends in town that work with a
whole bunch of different suppliers and
you know just it funds all the products
they need for for their YouTube videos
where there's cocktails or barbecue or
sewing and knitting and all that stuff
there's a lot of power in that
jabin Beth asks since you're in Canada
do you have a U.S and Canada like Amazon
affiliate set up and how do you manage
that
I do um you can you can sign up to
really all of them if you if you have
the viewership uh for me my two
dominance places are the US first and
foremost and then Canada's like second
or third on the list and they all you
sign up for both they sync together and
you can toggle back and forth between
the two the two platforms on Amazon uh
to check your stuff
um I think uh Amazon one link connects
those two accounts too so if if it's
just a general link if it's a US link
then it's clicked on by someone in
Canada it will automatically use that
one link that's attached behind the
scenes and divert that link to Canadian
If the product is there I could be wrong
with that but end of the day
yeah Amazon us pays me checks and
because that's how they do it if you're
out of country and Amazon Canada which
is not a lot uh because our population
is a lot lower they give me gift cards
because I just like I'm gonna spin it
anyways yeah yeah yeah man I love it in
fact Chris asked uh do you get digital
or actual checks you know again there's
all kinds of affiliate programs and um
and so Jaden mentioned and you know the
U.S sends him a check across the border
um you can sign up for direct deposit
you can also have checks you know
directly to you we we actually here in
the US we get our UK Amazon checks
physically and our Amazon check they do
get mailed to us uh and it's not direct
deposit and even to this day there's
some things that we still get physical
checks from we get a lot of direct
deposit as well
um
I had a brand we're gonna bring Lucia on
I had a brand contact me to use parts of
my review video and their product for
their ads linking back to me my channel
is so new so I am more interested in the
traffic was that a good move what do you
think Lucia is that question have you
had anybody that's wanted to collaborate
with you or
um you know be interested in your
likeness or your content yet
yeah so I'm just trying to understand
the question so the brand wants to use
part of her review video in their ads
right yes
okay I'm just promising to link back no
compensation
okay yeah so yeah put in the link back
to the to her video but no compensation
um you know I think for me when when I
was getting this kind of uh contacts
from uh from brands
I would say that the first thing that I
would do is to look if I already do the
the review video that means I really
like the brand and I like the the um the
the product and this could be a good
opportunity to make an alliance with the
brand and also bring people that are
looking into that product into my
channel since since my channel was small
maybe at that point and then I can
connect the two right so I think it's a
good opportunity to work with the brand
but I would also try to connect with
them communicate and see how it's going
to work but I think it's a good
opportunity to connect with the brand
and also with the people that are
visiting their website which of course
if you're talking about their product
then maybe these people are also going
to be interested in your content right
because you're talking about topics that
are related to this product so I think
it'll be a good opportunity to make
another alliances and look into the
future and see how to build a path yeah
I agree I think that early on you know
saying yes a lot is is a huge uh like
this is kind of just a general principle
I've learned in business when you're
just getting started you actually kind
of want to say yes to everything some
things like maybe you're doing client
work you say yes to every client you
have a lot of bad clients but you learn
a lot yes to every speaking Gig if you
get invited to speak I remember I drove
I prepared for a couple weeks I drove
across Vegas for an hour I drove to a
room at this hotel the fiesta and there
was 400 chairs and there was a stage set
up and I will just never forget they
invited me to Keynote speak
and I got up on stage
and there was five people in the room
one of them was the event promoter one
of them was his wife and the three
people that came to the event in a room
for full of uh 400 shares and you can
imagine as I made a point point point
point point point it echoed across the
room
and I just this those are your early
days where you're just showing up you
just gotta say yes and so you may you
know oh they're gonna use my likeness
they're not gonna pay me to link back to
my stuff or whatever just say yes I mean
early on of course do your due diligence
but but when you're starting getting the
experience building the portfolio you
know getting your stuff out there as you
grow
then your your prices go up your value
goes up you know the co-author of
YouTube Secrets my friend Benji they
have explicit details about whether to
use Judy his wife's likeness they go oh
you want to keep using her likeness for
three months six months a year that it's
gonna cost a lot of money because she
has a real brain a personal brand that
has gone up in value so that's some of
the things that I've kind of learned on
the journey uh but I would agree that I
think just getting awareness out there
when you're just starting is a really
really great idea what could you do if
you find out a brand is using your
videos without permission
um
invoicing
yeah just a lot about an invoice yeah
now this is actually personal story
because like I got started when I
started uh my video production years ago
my video production coming years ago
um it was focused on video marketing
right and so when you have a video
marketing background you know the power
of video and when brands use video
content they can make thousands and tens
of thousand dollars in sales because of
that one video and last winter I had a
brand I did a review for a company they
sent me the product and for free I did
the review and then attached the
affiliate links to it all that stuff
um and then probably like eight months
later they took that review downloaded
it from YouTube somehow and cut out my
intro cut out my outros
um and put their branding over top of it
and a friend of mine who's also in the
barbecue Niche sent me a Facebook
message saying hey do you know that
these guys guys are using this this
video to run ads like Facebook ads with
and I'm like no I so you send me the
link checked it out send an email to the
to the CEO of that company and said hey
I'm really glad that you uh really enjoy
this review and you're using it on
Facebook ads however I didn't give you
permission and this is property
protected or copyright protected to me
and
um so I'm gonna have to invoice you for
sponsorship uh package
um and yeah end of the day they did they
did pay it
um he kind of got upset with his
marketing team fair enough and
um you know it's end of the day those
companies if they actually would have
reached out to you in the first place
would have got a better end product
because it's more custom to what they're
actually looking for that rather than
just using a generic piece and trying to
fit it into a into their campaigns and
so yeah I invoice them and um it was
great it was sort of an added bonus
because it was like in in December right
before Christmas and that paid for all
my Christmas presents from the boys so
it was pretty that's unbelievable that's
that's super cool one time uh my my
likeness showed up in a Facebook ad and
all we were able to do was the ad just
got taken down they just were they took
a YouTube video to make it look like I
was promoting a product and so uh that's
a really great question
um David asks Lucia how did you manage
your time with creating content for
YouTube courses and patreon any time
management tips
yeah that's a great question because I
know it takes a lot of time
um and you know one thing that I've
learned is that planning is very
important and actually Heather talks
about this a lot uh she talks about I
think she calls it boxes so you have uh
what I do is actually have a calendar
and I have a written calendar I used to
do it on Trello which is also really
good if you like apps so in Trello you
can actually divide your activities and
what you what you want to do even by
color so you actually organize it with
deadlines and everything but then I
discovered that for me I when I'm
working in the computer I'm actually
working on the screen all the time I get
distracted so I'm like you know what I'm
just gonna get my agenda and I'm gonna
actually write everything that I have to
do and then I actually just follow the
plan and
um I actually feel that when you plan
ahead when you plan your week ahead and
you actually know what you're gonna do
in the day is this your first to
actually actually do it and if you get
to the day and you're sick or you you
have something else come up because
obviously that also happens
then because you have a plan you can
actually interchange the boxes with me
okay so then maybe I can do this on
Monday and then I can move this on
Tuesday and another thing that I can say
is that I used to put a lot on my plate
so now I'm a little bit more okay you
know what I'm gonna work and I'm gonna
work from I don't know eight to six but
then I also have to limit myself in the
activities I put in my week so I can
actually check and it's actually a good
feeling as well so that gives you energy
to keep going but yeah I think planning
is very important using an agenda
finding an app that works for you or
just your your notebook or things like
this yeah but I would recommend that you
watch uh videos with Heather about
organization because that really helped
me
yeah in fact that's tomorrow's session
um do not miss session number seven the
five hour YouTube Work Week
um Heather really she revolutionized my
life too you know I'm more creative bent
you know time to me is not a fixed thing
it's more like music or color it's just
kind of a Vibe you know what I mean like
just what do we feel uh I think media
team still feels that way sometimes when
I just kind of vibe in and uh riding on
a cloud of memes and random
chat conversations I'm having with
myself while Melissa Caputo is actually
trying to get things done and that's
horrible leadership and I'm trying to
improve but all that to be said Heather
really helped me use Google Calendar
calendar blocking planning ahead
strategy and that's that's huge if
you're gonna crush on YouTube this year
you got to master your time you got to
really be responsible and and dominate
your calendar and you can't let your
calendar dominate you
um and I know a lot of questions are
coming in I'm excited I'll stay on here
a little bit to answer questions but I
really want to honor uh um plants and
Lucia and Jaden can you just show your
love and um uh shout out a big love
thank you to them I'll answer a few more
questions about uh we have some
questions coming in about brand deals
affiliate marketing General things as
well as a few questions about the bundle
but
um as we sign off jabin uh final
thoughts just kind of two sentences on
man your perseverance you've been doing
this for almost a decade now you're full
time now a little bit of encouragement
for us through the ups and downs of
being a creator
yeah I I always come back actually to
something I heard you say one time where
it says overnight success takes 10 years
which really just points to the fact
that this is a long-term game if you're
if you're sort of going into it like I
have friends that are like I'm gonna
start a YouTube channel and they have
these big projection numbers uh for like
the first you know six months of their
YouTube Journey
um you know I think I think you just
need to
go into it one step in front of the
other do the best that you can in the
season of life that you can but don't
stop
um
overnight success takes 10 years just
press record all of those things that
Sean has been saying for years all add
up to longevity in this because it is a
grind it is a struggle at times you know
the amount of times I've wanted just to
quit
um
you know I'm sure I'm sure all you guys
have felt that over the years too so
strong and uh Lucia how about you what's
what have you learned on this last
couple years yeah I'm just nodding
because I totally agree with David
um you know I can tell yeah this is uh a
marathon as well as Sean says too is not
a Sprint and I can tell you in the three
years that I've been doing this there
have been many times that I'm like
okay why why am I doing this and I have
to remind myself because sometimes it
can be difficult it can be very tiring
it can be hard sometimes the numbers are
not there and it can get you down but I
think one thing that really helps me
is to remember the mission behind what I
am doing what I am what I am doing what
is my why why am I doing this I think of
the people that I'm getting to know I
think all the people that I'm helping I
think also of my personal wise and that
is actually what push me pushes me
through and sometimes I even tell Yan if
Sean for example Heather didn't exist if
they didn't I know that I mean I think
that they also have this moment
sometimes but they look at their why and
that's why now I am able to also look at
my why and also help other people
so I would recommend that I think when
you get low that sometimes it's gonna
happen uh just look at your why and
another thing that I would also
recommend is to surround yourself with a
community that is going to help you and
support you in this journey for example
for me I know that it helps me a lot to
go to the VRA group on Facebook because
these people actually are going through
this two very similar Journeys as me and
then we actually help each other out
because we actually sometimes comment on
the we just post on the group you know
what I'm having a bad day I don't see
the numbers and I'm just I just don't
know where else to go and then you get
all of this support because everyone
understands because everyone goes
through this so yeah I hope to see you
there because we actually really support
each other and that really makes a
difference
so thank you so much Lucia and Javen
appreciate you so much and thanks for
sharing your wisdom and your heart and
your tips today I see so many people
saying they want to re-watch this
session Lucia somebody wants to have you
on their podcast and so we'll see if
they can tag you or something there in
the comments uh but shout out some love
for them
so I've got some of your brand new
questions to answer but smash the like
button if you got value out of that
session I would love to hear the aha
moment that stood out to you and just as
a reminder you know uh both jabin and
plants and Lucia are a part of video
record academy and our best offer of the
year is happening right now so if you've
been on the fence
um if you go to learnvideo2023.com if
you know that in 2023 you're serious
about YouTube someone asked earlier
where we will we be able to help you
find your Niche or your topic our
YouTube Niche Finder course is included
in this bundle somebody asked earlier
what about building my confidence on
camera our camera confidence course is
included in this if you have questions
about tech we have our video creation
Made Simple workshop and then of course
our core program called video ranking
Academy and so all of that's available
for a limited time on this special price
with this special bundle at
learnvideo2023.com and so um this would
be the time to jump in and with that
some really good questions came in
though just related to Brand deals and I
wanted to answer those and give you some
of my best advice a lot of people asked
how do you know if brands are legit when
they contact you a lot of times some of
the Instagram DMS you get like hey we
want to send you free stuff just pay
shipping or some different things
there's a lot of scams that can happen
there one of the best things you could
do is Google the brand and even look
them up in BBB the Better Business
Bureau a lot of times you'll find that
there's a low rating you'll find when
you spend a little bit of time on Google
that it actually just kind of is a scam
and so when possible you want to work
with established Brands and chances are
they'll have an established website that
you can dig a little bit deep into
um a question that's been consistent is
how many subscribers or videos should
you have before reaching out to Brands
and what we like to recommend is you
want to have an established presence
there's no magic number but let's say
you have five to ten videos it shows
that your YouTube channel at least has
started and been somewhat consistent
another way to be established is to have
a clear cover image a clear Avatar a
Clear Channel name
and even a clear brand consider plants
and Lucia she has five videos out
they're all on Plants she uploads a
cover image plants and Lucia she applies
for Amazon and they go okay well we have
gardening tools and feed and all kinds
of lights for Gardens and containers for
different plants and so on and so forth
it's a very aligned affiliate program
and she has a channel that started then
it's a matter of getting qualified sales
within a certain window of time and
that's just for the Amazon Associates
program but what I would recommend is
being established we talk about this in
depth in our program called video
ranking Academy but that would be my
best advice is get a little bit of
momentum be established be getting
there's no reason really to apply day
one because you're not going to have
enough traffic anyways what is enough
traffic that means views that would be I
don't know 50 to 100 views of video
would be a good time to start but I also
don't want to limit this one why because
remember Heather Torres reached out to
the curriculum company that her and her
husband Isaiah would normally spend
sixteen hundred dollars a year on
purchasing curriculum and was like hey
would you consider doing some kind of a
brand collaboration she initiated that
conversation by sending an email and
practically I believe she was under 2
000 subscribers at the time so you could
do it smaller than that but she wasn't
gigantic
wasn't crazy momentum
but here's a huge key to Brand deals
it was homeschool moms it was a very
specific Channel a specific Niche if you
were just punching a posting a bunch of
random Youtube shorts and you got to 2
000 subscribers but you email a brand
and they're like I don't even understand
what your channel is about they might
give you something to promote they may
do something with you but you're going
to be in your place of power on YouTube
if you figured out your clear Niche you
figured out a clear brand a clear topic
you don't need a huge audience we call
these micro influencers you need the
Right audience that that brand wants to
reach
and so uh that's what Ron has asked as
well you know I'd say 500 to a thousand
subscribers is kind of a good Target
um and that you could get going there
um so if we don't have a niche will the
academy help with niches or do you have
to have one at the start yeah absolutely
so one of the things that I really want
to point your attention to is one of my
favorite programs I've ever created it's
called the YouTube Niche Finder it's
brand new it just came out and it
doesn't just cover beginner stuff the
YouTube Niche Finder covers some really
Advanced marketing and positioning
things remember what patrickbet David
said at the beginning of this stream he
said if you position yourself right
you can do really well in any economy
that's really what that program is all
about so that you're positioned right at
the intersection of what you're
passionate about at the intersection of
what you're proficient at and also at
the intersection of what is going to be
most profitable and so uh we will walk
you through that process in that program
finally
um
uh lots of questions on how do you know
if Brands aren't scams Google it
definitely Google it how do you go about
approaching companies also what do you
reply with when someone says what do you
have in mind
um Sean reach out uh here's a final
couple final tips as we land the plane
hit like if you've been getting value
today and um
uh Twitter
you ready for a hack
build out your LinkedIn account
and figure out somebody working at the
company you want to reach out to figure
out who the marketing director is on
LinkedIn figure out who like there may
be a director of brand deals but it
could just be their CMO Chief marketing
officer or a marketing assistant you
just want to get in touch with the real
human at the company so you could you
could use LinkedIn I like to tweet
companies they may they're probably not
following me so I I gotta monitor the a
while back because I tweeted I had a
canned tweet meaning what does canned
mean there's canned responses in Gmail
it means you write out the text one time
save it so what I said was I was like
Hey Asus you know hey ViewSonic on
Twitter and you at reply the brand I
said
um I'm a tech YouTuber do you ever work
with like YouTube creators let me know
and what will happen is I'll either get
ignored
or they follow me in DM me or they reply
publicly and they say fill out this form
you also could go to people's websites
and there's a lot of times a form form
there Sean where there is a form on a
Brand's website and then you select why
you're reaching out do you have a
customer service question is it
marketing and PR and you just say why
you're reaching out and one of the
biggest things to know no matter how big
or small you are is everybody's really
busy and you should assume that's your
contact reach out is going to be missed
not ignored
this is a killer mentality that you need
to have everybody full lock in with me
on this one
even if they are ignoring you I want you
to assume they just didn't see it
and to keep reaching out periodically
until someone officially says no now
don't be a weird stalker if someone says
please stop emailing me you should stop
emailing them come on ladies you had a
guy you were like stop calling me and
he's still calling you that's that's
that's no go stalker moves right there
but if if they have it said stop
emailing assume they didn't see it it
might be going to junk it might be going
to spam the person there might have just
been a rotation of staff that former
marketing directors no longer there
whatever so that's why I will create a
here's a tip create a
Google sheet which is like an Excel
spreadsheet you can use Google Sheets
for free of just like the different
brands and people you potentially want
to reach out and then just rotate
through it tweet them once a quarter
email them once a quarter email them you
know reach out on LinkedIn and and check
in periodically because what will end up
happening is they won't be like oh yeah
I was ignored they're like oh I never
saw it they're like you caught me at the
right time
you know that's the same is true for you
you gotta you got DMS coming at you you
got emails coming at you you subscribe
to that you know that clothing store and
they're still emailing you and you
subscribe to that text message you're
getting hit with all kinds of stuff so
it's just like we're living in a noisy
world the mentality you just want to
have is follow-up the fortune is in the
follow-up you want to have a consistent
follow-up mentality that does not rude
and the only time it becomes rude is
when they go we do not want to work with
you or we're not working with YouTube
creators right now well then don't start
don't keep emailing them but if they
ignore you they're not ignoring you they
missed it and so Sean the key is not
just reaching out in an appropriate way
but also doing it consistently too many
people emailed three brands and they're
like there's no brand deals now you got
to email 300 and then tell me there's no
brand deals because you'll get replies
and then when you have a reply Sean you
got to get creative and that's why I
want to invite you uh if if you or
anybody else is serious you should join
this program because the the key is you
are the leader
like what do you say if they say what do
you have in mind if you have nothing in
mind you're the creative director it's
your tube like your tube channel your
YouTube channel is you should be
thinking hey okay I'm going to integrate
you into my video podcast hey I could
make a video for you that highlights
your product hey I could shout out your
product as an ad read and if all this
stuff sounds kind of overwhelming we're
here for you to help you go to another
level that's what learn video 2023 is
all about like this is real as you can
see we just talked about seven ways to
make a thousand dollars but jabin and
Lucia they're making way more than that
that's just a starting point
if you want to really join the Creator
economy and make this a career if you
want to eventually go part-time
full-time doing this if you want to
figure out not just how to make a decent
living but really make a significant
income a six-figure income a seven
figure income like we go into depth in
that and you're going to be learning
from a faculty that has the real
experience as some people say the real
receipts in fact just as a reminder as
we land the plane today this full-time
Creator course the red one in the upper
right hand corner that is just an extra
bonus that's only available though until
the end of the challenge and so on
October 28th at midnight you could still
get the savings of everything else here
but you can get that additional course
which is a two-day event where we went
deep and the think media team recorded
our step-by-step tactics for what is the
shortest path to going full time to the
point of what do I say after a brand
responds to me we got you you're gonna
learn everything you need to know inside
of of this program and so much more and
you may have a lot of questions so just
head over to learnvideo2023.com If you
happen to be watching this stream on um
you know YouTube we we were taking these
evening streams putting them on the
podcast Channel thanks for being here if
you could hit the like button that'd
mean the world to me if you learned some
stuff today but check out the YouTube
description or go to
learnvideo2023.com to see this and if
you've been in the challenge remember
tomorrow is our final session by the way
there is still time to join the
challenge at tube1kchallenge.com you're
not going to want to miss not just the
last session but also the replays are
only up for a couple more days to catch
up on any sessions that you miss but
head over to learnvideo2023.com where um
myself the think media team can connect
with you if you have any questions about
the bundle and uh now is definitely the
time I'll see you tomorrow Stella thank
you for being here uh Georgette says I
learned so much I appreciate you super
grateful for you and thank you David for
shouting out VRA there's there is a lot
of info in VRA and there's a lot more
than just VRA included in this bundle so
super grateful that you are seeing the
value you inside of that you know
remember that this is backed by our
30-day think media satisfaction
guarantee like I believe so much in this
program that if you take a chance and
you invest in this you're not going to
be disappointed whether it's 29 minutes
from now or 29 days from now if for any
reason you would just say Sean I'm not
happy this isn't quite what I thought it
was we'll give you a full refund I know
that this program is going to give you
everything that you need to thrive and
succeed on YouTube You're Going to find
that it's worth 50 to 100 times more
than the low price discount that we have
available right now at
learnvideo2023.com so take the leap jump
inside of the program you can read all
of these details over there and David
thanks for your kind words super pumped
that um you are a part of the community
and thank you everyone for being here
today we'll see you on uh session number
seven tomorrow click or tap the screen
for another video from the think media
podcast you know and until then